[Musique]
bonsoir à tous on se retrouve dans ce
nouveau numéro du sky échos le magazine
qui vous raconte les aventures
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines et pour débuter
cette nouvelle année nous sommes chez
holt rixe une success story
saint-quentinoise en 2021 cette start up
a réalisé 170 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et elle vient
d'inaugurer son nouveau magasin basée à
coignières qui est juste derrière moi
nous reviendrons sur la stratégie de
cette entreprise créée en 2008 et elle
poursuit aujourd'hui son aventure en
partenariat avec décathlon ou encore
troc vélo dans le vélo d'occasion
c'est au programme de ce trente deuxième
numéro du sky et co spécialisée dans la
production de structures gonflables la
start up here captif a été racheté par
michelin objectif structurer cette
société en hyper croissance avec 170
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en 2021 hall tricks poursuit son
ascension économique
cette start up du e-commerce du vélo va
renforcer en 2022 son engagement dans
l'économie circulaire enfin direction le
technocentre renault de guyancourt pour
une rencontre avec anthony zamani farhi
il est pilote composants enjoliveurs de
roues implantée à trappes l'entreprise
erp captif a été racheté par le géant du
pneumatique michelin
la société saint-quentinoise créé en
2017 est spécialisé dans la production
de structures gonflables en 2020 elle a
multiplié son chiffre d'affaires par
quatre et aujourd'hui elle poursuit son
évolution avec le groupe michelin les
détails dans cette séquence décryptage
[Musique]
durant la crise qu vide en fait les deux
sociétés avaient commencé à travailler
ensemble en fait sur une thématique de
coussins gonflables à usages médicaux
lorsqu'emmanuel fievet le fondateur de
deir captifs c'est s'est manifestée
commettre comme étant vendeurs de sa
société de sa start up les pourparlers
se sont engagés durant l'année 2021
[Musique]
le groupe michelin va apporter à air
captifs une capacité d'industrialisation
le groupe michelin a développé de
l'innovation dans le domaine des
composites flexible par son expérience
dans le pneumatique et va apporter cette
compétence en particulier dans les
textiles techniques air captifs apporte
à michelin un premier ancrage qui va
permettre de de croître et de réaliser
davantage de chiffre d'affaires dans un
domaine au delà du pneumatique
[Musique]
et
déjà situé à coignières rôle trice vient
de changer de magasin passant de 480 m²
à 1200 mètres carrés une surface
commerciale dédiée aux vélos aux
activités extérieures avec un atelier de
réparation et plein de nouveautés hall
tricks une start-up devenue grande pour
en parler nous sommes avec gary ans à
son fondateur bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors quel bilan de l'année 2021 faites
vous alors un beau bilan c'est une année
contre l'autre sur proche des 30 % de
croissance on a recruté environ 100
collaborateurs sur l'année et on a
ouvert sur la fin d'année de trois
nouveaux magasins dont une refonte où
nous sommes aujourd'hui du coup vous
avez aussi un partenariat que vous avez
pu tester cette année avec décathlon
vous avez aussi racheter 30 vélos c'est
ça exactement donc décathlon alors
effectivement c'est notre partenaire
actionnaires on est très libre autonome
aux côtés du groupe troc vélo en est un
bel exemple on a fait l'acquisition en
février troglos ses leaders du vélo dans
l'occasion est donc c'est pour nous un
réel projet parce qu'on a envie
d'accélérer dans la partie circularité
donc plutôt de le faire en partant de
zéro on a décidé de faire l'acquisition
du leader en la matière comment ça s'est
passé qu'est ce que vous a apporté ces
deux partenariats qu est-ce qui vous ont
apporté
décathlon c'est d'être aux côtés d'un
partenaire qui comprenne notre métier
nos enjeux et qui nous soutient dans une
stratégie trop de vélo c'est un c'est
une opportunité d'accélérer beaucoup
plus vite et de racheter une marque est
déjà très forte sur son segment avec une
communauté parce que c'est plus de
quasiment millions d'utilisateurs et
plus de 60000 annonce au quotidien
présente sur la plateforme et donc de
pouvoir jouer sur ce qu'on fait depuis
treize ans le neuf et la partie
occasions et crée donc cette circularité
dont je parlais entre les deux vous en
parliez vous êtes vous avez 13 ans
d'existence vous avez été créée en 2008
vous l'avez créé commencent à évoluer
tous à présent j'étais seul dans un
garage aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'être
aux côtés d'un peu plus de 300
collaborateurs
créative géniaux passionnés et donc ça
vous a amené en 2021 clôturer l'année un
peu au dessus des 170 millions d'oeufs
euros de volume d'affaires l'aventuré
entreprenariale a commencé sur le
digital
aujourd'hui vous investissez dans des
magasins réels disons voilà du concret
du présentiel vous agrandissez même
certains magasins en présentiel vous
êtes un peu à contre-courant de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en fait à travers
la crise sanitaire
c'est un projet qui est piloté depuis
quelques années qu'on appelle omni canal
chez nous l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir être
présents sur les différents formats
existants au contact de nos utilisateurs
effectivement depuis un an ou deux en or
décalage parce que le monde du retail
physique est plutôt tendance à se
digitalise et pour faire face
malheureusement aux vagues qu'on connaît
sur les contextes sanitaires non par l
inverse on a besoin de contacts on a
besoin de monter nos produits on a
besoin de mettre à disposition du
service en local et donc dans cette
logique là parce qu'on est déjà plutôt
musclé sur la partie digital c'est de
venir aux quatre coins de la france
malgré une présence à travers des
magasins qui font 300 à 1200 mètres
carrés comme celui où nous sommes quelle
est la part aujourd'hui de voir si
chiffre d'affaires sur le digital et sur
le présence hier encore les grandes dans
les grandes masses c'est 5% côté rites
et le physique et 95 encore en ligne et
du coup quel est l'objectif à travers
cette stratégie n'est décrire cette
farce l'objectif c'est de toujours
contenté l'utilisateur et d'augmenter
l'expérience client donc je peux avoir
acheté un produit en ligne mais j'ai
besoin d'un entretien en local je peux
avoir besoin d'un conseil pour me
décider donc je vais aller le chercher
en local j'ai besoin d'être ajustés sur
ma posture d'avoir des capteurs on
appelle scène études posturales ou
d'étudier ma foulée pour savoir quel est
le produit qui correspond le mieux en
vélo ou en running à mon utilisation je
vais la voir en local ça va être plus
simple aussi c'est une possibilité pour
nous de créer de la communauté en local
d activation pour partager avec nos
utilisateurs et donc en quelques
chiffres c'est quoi l'ambition d'un à
six magasins on en aura huit si on se
reparle en milieu
en milieu d'année et probablement 15
d'ici 4-5 ans justement parlons de cette
année des millions d'yeux quelles vont
être les grandes dates de cette année
2022 pour l'atrix alors les grandes
dates c'est effectivement cette
acquisition de trop gros qui encore
assez récente on va fêter les un an dans
un mois on vient de sortir la nouvelle
version du site là
qu'on a besoin encore des trophées donc
c'est une grosse accélération sur la
partie occasion c'est je pense un moment
de respiration aussi sur la partie
retail pour monter en puissance sur nos
différents magasins et puis ça sera
aussi l'année de l'international parce
que pour eux le trx l'international
c'est un peu plus de 20% on veut
augmenter cette part là on est présent
en allemagne en espagne en italie on a
besoin de rendre la marque all tricks
plus visible à l'échelle européenne bien
c'est tout ce qu'on vous souhaite garder
en scène merci beaucoup merci à vous de
nous avoir reçus ici et on va tout de
suite rejoindre sébastien chartier le
responsable de cette boutique pour
découvrir ce nouveau magasin un concept
magasin parce qu'on voit que c'est assez
particulier et voir que holt rice est en
train de changer de deux plateaux comme
on dit qu'on espère
[Musique]
bonjour sébastien chartier bonjour
nouvelle boutique plus grande que le
dernier magasin à coignières avec de
nombreuses nouveautés tout à fait donc
aujourd'hui on a triplé la surface du
magasin pour pouvoir donner un peu plus
d'espacé à chaque univers donc
aujourd'hui on a dessiné un peu tous les
univers dans le magasin on a rajouté
aussi des univers qu'on travaillait très
bien sur le site et que je ne pouvais
malheureusement pu travailler en
physique notamment le running et
l'outdoor si une part importante de sa
démarche et 6 à aujourd'hui oui c'est ça
ça reste une très grosse part de marché
et c'est aussi une activité
complémentaire du cycliste d'accord
parce qu'il ya des personnes qui font du
vélo mais aussi dur unis les gens qui s
entraînent tout à fait y'a bon il ya des
gens qui font du triathlon donc là ils
font les disciplines il ya des gens
aussi qui font du coup ce l'odeur avait
avait un rapport avec tous les sports
extérieurs voyage à vélo et c'est donc
aujourd'hui entre le gravel le vtt tout
la part montagne ça a du sens puis une
partie aussi alors nouvelle non parce
que vous faites ça depuis mai de winne
2021 geoffroy une partie second life
c'est le l'économie circulaire dans le
trx tout à fait donc aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'on a beaucoup plus de
place on peut se permettre de reprendre
beaucoup plus de vélo sur place donc
c'est que maçon complet donc de coût
aujourd'hui on rachète les vélos des
clients
tous les vélos anciens ou même les gens
qui veulent s'en séparer partir sur
autre chose donc aujourd'hui le client
vient avec son vélo ont fait une
estimation
on fait des réparations s'il ya lieu
dans l'avoir et derrière on lui rachète
son vélo il peut repartir sur un vélo
neuf ou alors on peut lui racheter tout
simplement son vélo et derrière on leur
propose à la vente avec une garantie
supplémentaire et c'est ce qu'on voit
ici en fait c'est ça c'est ces vélos là
alors il ya de tout il ya du vélo
électrique je suppose et du vtt ya du
vélo de route reprend tout type de vélo
que ce soit du vélo enfant aux vélos
adultes de route vtt tout type de vélo
est bienvenue et donc c'est précis des
petites réparations ça peut être sûr par
exemple le pneu ça peut être
effectivement il faut que les bleus
puissent durer au moins une bonne année
en suivant le kilométrage défini que la
transmission elles soient récentes voire
neuf donc quand les vélos viennent avec
des transmissions vraiment très usagers
on repart sur d'une alors combien de
personnes ont été embauchées suite à
l'ouverture de ce magasin indécent de
oui c'est ça la voyez on a ouvert depuis
mi décembre
donc on a embauché deux personnes
supplémentaires et on a une prévision
d'embauché encore deux autres personnes
cette année qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour 2022 sébastien bach
beaucoup de vélo beaucoup de clients
bon je dirais météo propice à l'activité
du plein air merci sébastien de rien
responsable du magasin holt rixe à
coignières et le sky ico se poursuit
ils sont onze mille salariés à
travailler au quotidien au technocentre
renault de guyancourt de multiples
activités autour de la recherche et
développement et de l'ingénierie
autour des véhicules parmi eux il y à
anthony zamani farhi il est spécialisé
sur l'activité autour des enjoliveurs
des roues rencontre dans cette séquence
ma vie de salarié
je m'appelle anthony zamagni farhi j'ai
27 ans je travaille au technocentre
renault et ma fonction ici c'est d'être
ce qu'on appelle pilote composants
enjoliveurs de roues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon activité au quotidien consiste à
être garant des règles techniques que
métier je suis responsable technique des
enjoliveurs de roues mon but c'est que
le client soit au maximum satisfait mon
objectif est de permettre au design de
concevoir l'enjoliveur le plus beau
possible et qui répondent à nos règles
techniques côté nouveaux enjeux neri
parti moment où renault va se demander
sur quelle sera l'ange oliver de demain
du véhicule de demain et c'est là où moi
je vais devoir souvent intervenir pour
donner mes préconisations techniques
personnellement j'interviens beaucoup en
france avec l'équipe en local mais on
est en support de tous les équipes au
monde qu'on peut avoir que ce soit au
brésil en roumanie en inde en corée
[Applaudissements]
je suis content de venir travailler ici
chez renault parce que je pense il ya
mama pied ça mais ma fonction quand je
fais un enjoliveur j'ai un lien
particulier avec le client parce que si
je fais un oliver qui au final est beau
tout simplement mais je sais que le
client peut être content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une bonne
année 2022 vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]